we've already talked about linear demand
functions that actually have changing
price elasticity as we go
as we go down the curve and we've shown
the extremes we've shown things that are
perfectly inelastic and things that are
perfectly elastic what i want to do in
this video it'll be a quick little video
is think about can we construct a demand
curve or at least understand what it
looks like that has a constant
elasticity across the curve and just for
fun let's make it a constant elasticity
of one so it has constant unit
elasticity of demand so let's think
about how we can create that and
hopefully it'll give us a little bit
more intuition on how this elasticity
business even works so let's draw our
axes
so i can
see there you go that is price
price
and that right there is quantity
quantity and let me put quantity now i
put one extra t there quantity
now let's put some numbers there that'll
just help us draw this this demand curve
that has unit elasticity at every point
at every price and every quantity so i'm
just going to put some numbers here so
let's say that this that right over
there is 10 so that's 10
or whatever we're doing and then this is
10 units per time period 10 units per
week or 10 units per month or whatever
else now we want
we want the absolute value of the
elasticity of demand to be equal to one
at all points and we're going to assume
that this curve is meets the law of
demand which means this price goes down
quantity demanded goes up so let's think
so it's going to be a downward sloping
so really we're going to say that the
elasticity of demand is going to be
equal to
negative 1. if we have a 1
decrease in price we're going to have a
1
increase in quantity and vice versa
so let's think about it
if we're up here if we're up here where
the price is near ten dollars and maybe
where the quantity is closer to one
dollars let's think about what a ten
percent movement in price would look
like a ten percent movement down it
would be roughly about this size
a ten percent movement would be roughly
there and i'm just trying to get the
general shape of this curve i'm not
going to go into the deep mathematics or
the calculus of it
so that is a ten percent price movement
down and we also want a ten percent
quantity movement up but remember our
quantity is only at one so ten percent
quantity movement up would only be would
only be ten percent of one so if we're
moving 10
in price downwards this is a 10
upwards in quantity so our curve up here
would look something like this it would
actually have to be quite steep now
let's think about what the curve would
look over here once again we want 10 for
both of them because we want this we
want the price elasticity of demand to
be one throughout the curve so if we go
over here 10 percent a 10 movement in
price so let's say we're down here where
price is where price is close to one
a ten percent movement in price is going
to be very small so 10 movement in price
is going to be like that it's going to
be like what's going to be roughly a
tenth of a of a movement so that's a 10
movement in price but a 10 movement in
quantity demanded over here it's going
to be much larger it's going to look
something like that because where the
quantity is approaching 10 so 10 percent
of that is about one unit just like that
so at this point in the graph it would
look something like this it would
flatten out a good bit just like that
and then when the price and the quantity
is about the same so let's say this
point right over here where the price
and the quantity is about the same
so let's say that this is
so that is 2 this is 3 this is 2
this is 3 right over here
your percent movements are going to be
the same but since the price and
quantity are the same the absolute
movements are also going to be the same
so at that point our curve should look
something like that it should have a
slope of one and so if you connect the
dots you get a the general shape of a
demand curve that has a price elasticity
of demand at negative one throughout the
curve or whose absolute value of the
price elasticity of demand is one so
let's just do that so the curve would
look something like
i'll just draw a dotted line it's easier
to do a do so it'll look something like
that it'll keep getting steeper as we
get the quantity closer to zero it'll
keep flattening out as the quantity
grows and grows and grows anyway
hopefully you found that interesting